[Music]
[Music]
what's up vlog just trying something a
little bit different here this is the
setup to this keynote I gave in Boise
Idaho one of the most in-depth best
talks I think I've given the QA was just
obnoxious off the charts bunch of
highlights emotion funny and probably
the most up to date thoughts on a lot of
my thinking around marketing attention
building businesses entrepreneurship
here in London great trip fought off a
cold and proud of myself
and and on the way back to New York a
couple of meetings in New York and then
into the weekend jets are two and two
let's see what happens in Cleveland this
weekend but I really really want to
start being you know in a place where
I'm always testing two channels is that
right on YouTube setting up longer form
content in the main channel that's what
I'm doing now
hack hack hack hack hack don't don't
listen to what I'm doing watch excuse me
don't listen to what I'm saying those
four a.m. wake-up calls don't listen to
what I'm saying watch what I'm doing you
didn't know thank you so much you know
what's interesting I was sitting there
and listening hey Dan
and I realized Jesus it's [ __ ] crazy
that I can literally give this entire
keynote in about one minute given the
context that was just created and I
think it's just gonna make sense to
everybody right which is everything
you've just heard is 100% mathematically
correct
the reason they spent a lot of money on
that [ __ ] rad ass video that you saw
is 100% correct and the reality is is
the only reason that I'm standing here
whatsoever and being you know feeling
good about who's watching me because so
many of you guys are doing your thing
out there is that I just respect the
[ __ ] out of both of them and I just
genuinely believe the rest of this room
doesn't that either it's 5149 or some of
you are a hundred percent math the world
I now live in these big agencies they're
100
cent art it's you know they have no
respect to sales and and that's it like
I literally feel like leaving thank you
like that's literally like but but but
it's interesting that that's really at
like honestly there's a lot of my energy
and I have a lot of time that I and I
know a lot of you and really I'll talk
for the next 20 minutes out of the
respect that I'm sure a lot of you don't
know who I am or context but I'd much
rather get into the Q&A part and just
answer the detailed [ __ ] that's on your
mind because the theory is simple like
it's just the same old [ __ ] it's math
and art and you better deploy it where
and then the thing that I think I've
done well I guess there's the thing that
I should probably actually now spend
some time on is why was I in Seattle
yesterday doing so the amount of three
days I have in my career now or
non-existent right I don't I don't speak
for free everything's about the
businesses that I run I don't like
leisure so like there's no free days
right like like everything is calculated
I do things for a reason why the [ __ ]
was I in Seattle yesterday spending a
free day which is a rarity for me it was
because I was talking about what I've
done but mainly I was trying to extract
value from an incubator in Seattle run
by tech stars around the voice space
these are people that are building
businesses and apps on top of Alexa and
Google home and things of that nature I
think the thing you know actually this
is pretty funny this since I'm soap
improv down I'm starting to realize huh
I've always thought that I respected you
know I literally just two minutes ago
said I just respect the art and science
better I don't think I'm really or nor
have I ever really been better or really
that good at others and I would actually
probably argue now that I'm thinking
there's plenty people that somewhat
respect both I think the thing that
actually in a lot of ways has worked for
me that I'd like to talk to you about
because I actually think if I think
about how much I respect everybody in
the room the thing that maybe I can
bring you the most value on is why do I
bet on things that tend to work out well
it's mainly because I'm willing to lose
money in the short term I think that I'm
will
to waste time and lose money much more
than most people because I'm patient as
[ __ ] even though my energy is frantic
right I know for a fact that whoever has
the best Alexis skill in this room is
gonna make a fortune in seven years bomb
wasting money and time trying to be that
person in this room and so I think the
other variable that you want to leave
this talk from besides if you only
believe in the creative or if you only
believe in the math how do you squeeze
those two together it's can you allocate
an additional 20% of your time and money
and mental energy to start betting on
where we're going instead of where we
are right now a lot of you are winning
because we're playing in where we are
right now
while all those [ __ ] are playing in
2009 the question is are you willing to
waste money while you're making money
right now being right on 2021 that is
what has kept me consistent I had an
email newsletter in 1996 that 91 percent
open rates I didn't want social media
like if I was making content back in the
day you would have seen me sad as [ __ ]
about social media I didn't want to
learn Twitter I didn't want to learn
tumblr I didn't want to like I had email
and you know SEM and SEO figured out I
was good it was probably the laziest
part of my career because it just worked
but I recognized that the thing that got
me here is never the thing that's gonna
take me to the next place and I think we
rest on our laurels when we've figured
[ __ ] out and so I'm spending an ungodly
amount of time on everything that isn't
the math it's incredible
that we now live in a world where the
people that are building great companies
in this and they do great and they make
a lot of money they deserve it because
they take things that we don't have to
worry about out of the equation and the
fact of the matter is math will always
be that one the quant part of our worlds
is always the thing that's going to be
scalable and then commoditize above but
things that aren't our the art the
creativity and most importantly the
intuition and then the audacity to leave
money on the table every single day of
your life
to invest in the world that you think is
gonna be there in 24 months and then you
have to be right otherwise you lose and
so to me it's very clear it's a little
bit of a left-field conversation and has
nothing to do with me being there
yesterday you need to get very serious
about sound because let me tell you
something about why what they make is
successful we care about only a couple
things as people money health religion
there's not a lot of things we really
really give a [ __ ] about but one of the
things that we care about and always
have but now we're at an all-time high
is time ooh BRR became a huge company by
selling time not transportation time is
imperative we don't like friction we
don't like friction on our landing pages
and we don't like friction in our lives
and everybody even when they don't have
a lot of money spend a lot of money on
convenience commune's is king time
matters and I'm gonna tell you right now
and you'll think back to this talk one
way or the other think back this talk
because this was the talk that made you
get very serious about investing into
audio or you'll think back to it when
other people are making real money real
opportunities changing the world
whatever they want to do with the
attention and you'll think about you
wish you started earlier and I lived
this whole life with social right and
it's it's fun for me because it's just
black and white and obvious so we're
gonna all be invested and winning on
time excuse me on audio because it saves
us time audio saves you time every
single person in this room when brushing
their teeth in 40 years will be
listening to some sort of voice telling
them what they're doing that day what
the weather is where they're going
what's happening it's just gonna be that
and if you're smart you can penetrate
somebody's first seven minutes every
single day of their lives and talk about
whatever the hell you want them to know
about and so I would give that a ton of
thought you know obviously between you
and me I'm sure a lot of you seen it
like it's not even close to too late to
start a podcast podcasts are imperative
ly important because people you know the
way we roll now is we can listen
and do something else it's hard to watch
one of my videos and do something else
it's super easy to listen to what I'm
talking about and do something else
anything that aligns you with the end
consumers time is an imperative Liebig
advantage for you and listen there's a
lot of people that are comedians and and
you hack theirs and actresses and things
of that nature you got to figure out how
you mold in into these new platforms you
got to figure it out but it's coming and
so to me the big things to really think
about is pairing art and science
together and then really recognizing the
consumer behavior because we're in the
later innings of social like we're in
mature platforms which means really good
things for Facebook stock you know but
doesn't mean as much for a lot of us I
mean I'm looking at somebody in the
crowd right now and I'm smiling the
whole time because we sat in an old
Vayner office and I was like guys this
vine thing I'm telling you and I got
them all together all of them and I was
like I'm telling you it's like you're
like I remember telling them you're all
gonna be famous in a year and I remember
looking at them and some may be lit it
was just so obvious it wasn't obvious to
me because I saw Twitter before that and
YouTube before that and it just it's the
same guys it's the same [ __ ] it's the
same [ __ ] over and over there's
underpriced attention and there's
overpriced attention
there's headline readers and there's
practitioners I mean let me give me an
example of headline reading versus
practitioners headline readers snapchats
dead practitioners holy [ __ ]
snapchats ad product is so under priced
cuz everybody thinks it's dead that it's
two dollars and 80 cents CPM to get in
front of everybody who's under 30 in the
world and at least in the US world in a
couple other countries and holy [ __ ]
the swipe up conversions of these people
since they live in that world are so
[ __ ] incredible there's no platform
on earth not YouTube and Facebook
combined that can get somebody under 30
to watch a three-minute video
continuously even remotely close to
snapchat and it's two [ __ ] dollars in
eighty cents of CPM practitioners versus
headline readers and this is a pretty
[ __ ] legit audience and I know a lot
of you
and I watch a lot of everything and
there's just a lot of people who
headline read there's a whole lot of
people who have a whole lot of opinions
about a whole lot of [ __ ] in here and
they've never done that thing thank you
mom
so it's it man like honestly it's gonna
be the same [ __ ] I'm gonna sit here
[ __ ] at 74 years old and I'm gonna be
like you know VR [ __ ] faces like how do
you know like you know it's just the
same [ __ ] like I really feel like I'm
done like I'd love to go into Q&A I
don't know where the runners are like
you know I'll tell you anything you want
to know like LinkedIn super super super
interesting to me right now just because
the by rattler they're really desperate
to become the b2b Facebook so they're
seducing the algorithms to try to big
the outcomes always pay attention who's
desperate always pay attention to who's
desperate right that's always where the
upper me I'm impossible
I'm expensive I have a book coming out I
[ __ ] myself out that's when you get me
right like that's how you get me it's
just not super complex is II snapchat
not so much momentum pay attention
always always always look to the other
direction of the conventional wisdom
because that's always where the [ __ ]
magic is understand that if you're the
best math math oriented person in this
room that you're vulnerable to the art
if you're just a creative bad news math
matters find somebody right that's what
this is and it's been this for the last
20 years and it's gonna keep going but I
will say the big white space for the
collective is sound what is your podcast
what is your Alexa briefing like what do
you say to everybody for the first 30
seconds in the world and how to use your
enormous attention on Instagram to get
ten hundred thousand people to download
it and then it's early so Amazon's like
who the [ __ ] is this person and they fly
you out now you're starting in the
commercial it's the same patterns my
friends it's the same patterns and then
ultimately overlaying everything I'm
talking about does your mouth match your
ambition there's a whole lot of
billionaires in here out their mouth
but they go to every [ __ ] concert on
earth and that's cool like [ __ ] make
40,000 it's not about the money it's
about do your actions match your
ambitions so that's the framework and
then the last thing got to figure out is
what you want in your work-life balance
in your legacy and how much money you
want and what you want to do with that
money and a lot of people get caught in
the rat race at the most basic level
followers and likes which is [ __ ]
ludicrous at the next level which is
pretty [ __ ] ludicrous - money without
realising you wake up and you're 47
you're like [ __ ] I didn't you know so
two frameworks the things I've just
talked about very easy to understand
second part this last minute a little
harder you got to get real into
self-awareness but once you know what
the [ __ ] you're about it's ironic and
intriguing how the [ __ ] just starts
happening not because you [ __ ]
thought it into reality it's because you
know what the [ __ ] you're doing and all
your actions map to that reality cool
thank you how many how many mics awesome
let's go you guys are in control on
again I don't have feelings Junior
what's up Oh Gary Eric thanks for being
here thanks mom
my name is Jerry with digital marketing
hacks and my question is I know you you
say that it's gonna end all with robots
killing everybody I hope so
but until then yes what role do you
think AI artificial intelligence and
robots have I mean are going to have in
the next five years in the marketing and
digital marketing space huge even in the
15 minutes that I've gotten a better
taste of what these characters are up to
they're gonna love it like the math
people are gonna love it because machine
learning and AI just do [ __ ] that we
shouldn't be doing like it's just
efficiency it's gonna have an enormous
thing like but the good news is like
there's so much that we still can do and
and so basically how I think about you
know ml and AI back at the pad is get me
to [ __ ] third and a half base and
I'll take care of the rest
and whatever AI can do for that cool and
whatever low priced employees can do
cool but like everybody is spending way
too much money to get the third and a
half base and then the magic is the last
part so that's what AI is gonna mean for
everybody here there's a lot of dumb
[ __ ] that people have assistance for or
managers for that's nonsense
zero value that the biggest say I
companies in the world are gonna get
their nut off on hey
hey it's uh it's really exciting to be
here in this room with you and everyone
here this is awesome appreciate it
yeah I'm really experiences that help
people save time yeah awesome I'm really
interested in experiences that are
time-bending and how people just lose
time and I'm interested in creating the
most hardcore drugs no no no so here we
go the world's most connective music
festival okay all right
we're festival goers are connecting with
each other like never before
yep and with the artists and the artists
with their fans okay and so in 2021 we
are now I'm talking about on the mixed
reality so 2021 got music festivals
connection the best time of people's
lives what do you see happening in the
context of music festivals that you're
excited about and that you're excited
about creating so if I dissect that
right couple things one thing I'm super
fascinated by that I would have never
seen and by the way I never spend any
time predicting like like voice not
predicting [ __ ] it's happening right but
I think I'm good at is like recognizing
winners when it's practical and then
going pot committed right which means
you'll lose money for a couple years and
then get it you don't lose for seven
years and never get there the thing
that's been super fascinating to me that
I would never thought which is Fox
social media is making people do more
[ __ ] in real life like literally some
dude is hiking right now just for the
[ __ ] Instagram photo
right so so what's been amazing about
music festivals is because everybody
here now is not only themselves but
they're the PR agent of themselves for
what they're putting out people are
going to more concerts than ever because
of that whole dynamic I think what
you're alluding to is kind of like
what's gonna happen in society like in
general like mixed reality things of
that nature it's you know it's gonna be
funny technology's making music you know
going to music grow and then it's gonna
take it away but I don't think it's as
soon as 2021 but I think that right now
a lot of music festivals are failing
because they all have the same [ __ ]
acts and it's just supply and demand and
so when you were first four or five six
years ago you win and now there's 87
micro festivals and big companies signed
the same 13 artists in a [ __ ] right so I
think there's a huge white space for the
next generation of that like the people
that the streets [ __ ] with right and
then and then I think that ultimately
it's gonna be really interested in just
in general what happens when we lived in
a mixed reality world I think the big
arbitrage the only thing that's gonna
break the Internet is VR but V ours
quite a ways away like nobody here
spends an hour on VR in a month in real
life so we're a long like it takes time
behavior takes time but eventually when
we're switching between completely
virtual like I don't even see you guys
right now my contact lenses have me in
Afghanistan switch it off I'm right here
switch it off in its AR and Santa Claus
is sitting right there you know Santa
you know that world I think is super
interesting and it's gonna change all
our businesses thanks man cool yep hey
Shawn Gary you just came back from
August and you said I'm bringing you to
fire new shows are coming out and you
took the askgaryvee show to Facebook
only I did so what are your latest
strategies and why for both YouTube and
Facebook I think you have to make
content that is native to the platform
you put it out on I've always thought
about that
I [ __ ] wrote a book called Jab Jab
hook
five years ago on this I wasn't doing
that so now that askgaryvee show is on
facebook watch and the dailyvee is on
youtube
wendy rock is where i'm gonna [ __ ] the
rock okay you know now i could say
what's up YouTube
whereas I couldn't do that before and
knows little nuances [ __ ] matter and
you know all the action is in those
little edges and so I broke them up
mainly because of Facebook video now
that there's watch I'm fascinated any of
you watch a show yet on Facebook watch
just raise your hands just curious
higher right so this intrigues me like
everybody you're asked to watch one not
because like I don't want [ __ ] I mean I
watched one the Lavar bball family
because I just want to see the [ __ ]
they're doing like to me this is the
most interesting thing that I'm doing
that the good market isn't you've got to
taste everything like if you want to win
and [ __ ] there's no way you're in
[ __ ] Boise Idaho if you don't want to
win right now no I mean that like like
like when I think about who's here I'm
like [ __ ] these people are hungry so
like to me 19 hands which means maybe 31
because people get shy to two weeks into
Facebook watch that haven't watched
that's that's that's it that's that's
where I play
that's my margin so that's why I did it
because I wanted to make them native I
have two active shows I needed to do
something on Facebook and because I
watched face actually [ __ ] I'll tell
you it's not fully announced yet but
I'll see how this goes because I watched
watch and I watched it for four you know
kind of like four days in a row looked I
understood what the [ __ ] they were doing
so I sent them an email I pitched them a
show and they bought it right so now
I'll have kind of anybody can put a show
on Facebook right like a page a watch
page which everybody should be doing
here I'll have my youtube you know show
and now I'm gonna have a produced by
Facebook show that's gonna get big dick
even more listen man I talk and like do
in and hustle and all this I just like I
do so much more than I talk which is
[ __ ] crazy cuz my mouth is always
running but I'm just doing I'm doing
doing doing because I'm tasting I'm
tasting I never think I'm fancy so many
people in here I know you like so many
people here make it a little bit get
fancy stop stop doing the [ __ ] that got
them there that's the minute you're
[ __ ] dead
okay Marshall I have a question is yeah
I there's a guy I fall in line you might
have heard of him his name is Gary
Vaynerchuk yes he told me to push all in
on whatever it is that you're good at
yes I'm making this big push as Marshall
live I'm going to everything live like
straight to ask me questions I love that
aspect of your brand so the question is
if everything is moving to voice is
live-streaming podcasts going to be end
up being bigger than say iTunes are
recording that you can come back to so
first of all you said something
interesting that we all do if everything
is moving to voice nothing moves nothing
is everything like we will always have
the written word you could have them do
you know much by reality there is
through long form written Facebook and
Instagram posts like if you sit in here
and you can write write long ass posts
on Facebook and Instagram and watch what
the [ __ ] happens we are humans we've
been around a long [ __ ] time bro
Marshall written word audio video [ __ ]
is locked in got it so it's not like
you're gonna lose it like [ __ ] if you're
great at smoke signals get the [ __ ] up
there you know like you know like
communication doesn't change the the
pillars of communication are set where
we communicate changes right and then
you have to be contextual right some
people are incredible at making a
six-second video I keep looking at him
because it's fun to see him I haven't
seen him all others aren't like I can't
put two [ __ ] sentences together in my
life I have five New York Times
bestselling books because I have a
ghostwriter because I didn't try to
become a great writer when the blogging
thing happened because I've been on my
strengths and so I do believe that
everybody here should bet on their
strengths and surround themselves with
their weaknesses
I actually think back to earlier
question I think AI and machine learning
is gonna help a lot of us in here who
are creative close the gap on a lot of
our weaknesses which is gonna be really
awesome you got it yep yeah I think a
lot of people in here using clickfunnels
or not have kind of come into a lot more
money than maybe
they've ever been used to making okay um
and in one of your previous sentences
you said yeah you only care about money
and all of a sudden you're 47 but then
you didn't finish a sentence I was
hoping to like hear you elaborate on
yeah I you know for I'm sure a lot of
people here real who let's say have come
into money it's not as great as
advertised for a lot of people some
people love it they like watches and
Lambos and houses and that's [ __ ] rad
like Mazel Tov you know other people
don't and you start questioning what the
[ __ ] right because when you're when
you've got nothing and you're on the
come up and you've got numbers in your
head whether it's a million or five or
three or whatever the [ __ ] it is it's
[ __ ] empty when you get there for a
lot of people and so you know I'm just
I'm just trying to make sure people are
being thoughtful there's just much like
what I just said the marshal like life
is pretty simple like people play on
legacy on family on money like there's
just a couple pillars I just think in
our space right now you know I know a
lot of you have heard me rant on this I
do think entrepreneurship has taken a
turn towards club promotion like you
know and like that's just dangerous not
it's just dangerous for the people
they're gonna it's not honorable give a
[ __ ] it's it's dangerous because people
don't realize they need to build a
business not a perception that they're
good at business
because nobody's you know when the
market crashes nobody's going to Vegas
with you when you work at Bank of
[ __ ] America you know I'm just trying
to get people to be more thoughtful sure
hey man how you doing I'm super well so
Russell and you were - last year I was
selling websites was getting really
frustrated yeah I wasn't helping people
felt like they weren't growing their
sales but they had a really nice site so
you guys inspired me to start a podcast
awesome didn't know exactly what for but
just like a [ __ ] those guys are doing
it I will - more along the lines of I
was listening to a podcast in the gym
host asked the other guy what would you
tell your 20 year old self and the guy
answered I would divorce my wife earlier
I was super pissed off I'm married with
two young kids and wanted to have a
podcast from a different perspective and
so you're later than God
two weeks ago I got to publish my
interview with Russell I've had Dean
grazi OC and so my question is number
one is how do you grow even further and
number two is not just for me but
anybody starting or in progress what
should your priorities be so let's sit
here
you know both both of those things I
can't answer because you need to decide
you know what first so you have to
define growing for me is growing being a
top 50 podcast I mean like we all get
into our micro games and by the way I
think micro games are good you know a
little short goals micro it's kind of
good you scratch it it's fun for a
little bit I think you got to have your
macro point of view like if you were if
you're telling me the truth that you
felt like the conversations were going
in the wrong directions and you want it
to go a different place well the answer
to your question is just do it every day
until you're dead right like that's my
plan my plan is you know hopefully it
gets me to like this one little funny
weird thing that I want to buy a
football team but other than that my
plan is to put out [ __ ] for free that is
historically correct so that people so I
can continue to live the life I'm living
which is I made the money I wanted to
make a long time ago but getting 50 60
70 emails 80 emails a day of people like
[ __ ] you helped me like that's just like
intoxicating but that's what gets me off
tonight and by the way
I'm not sure that like you know like I
understand why that wouldn't be
meaningful to somebody else like so you
just have to do what you have to do for
yourself
right like that's how you grow by
consistency you know you grow by you're
a year in you grow when you're 19 years
into your podcast more specifically in
terms of actual numbers yes taking the
what you've done and now like
specifically on the number aspect of it
what do you recommend in terms of taking
your platform and kind of skyrocketing
numbers by underpriced attention whether
that's buying ads on Facebook and
snapchat right now cuz they're under
priced if that's working with
influencers because many are still under
priced whether that's taking the high
risk of trying to make a 10 to $50,000
version of what you just saw their
incredible video because that one video
can be your Dollar Shave Club of your
brand saying yes to everything like if
you want it if you're hungry you do what
I did which is four years ago when I
didn't jump into podcasting right away
the first two years I just went on
everyone's and so I could have went to
sleep at 11:00 p.m. or I could have went
on Lois houses podcast 11:00 p.m. like
that was a decision it's just about
awareness like where are the eyeballs
and so just put your time and effort
into that some of its freeing some to
cost money you got it hey gay brother my
first time seeing you your honesty is so
beautiful and it's just wonderful
listening to appreciate someone's trying
to like build a brand yeah you don't get
a podcast and get more to Facebook and
all these other things to Colonel yeah
what kind of some tips you have for
building like a powerhouse team around
you to help you accomplish all these
things first it has to be practice to
stay here first has to be practical so
some people in your can afford people
other people can't so they either have
to learn how to do it themselves by
spending hours looking at YouTube videos
on how to or read or finding people like
we're an incredible gyro right now there
are so many kids 14 to 21 that want to
be creators and think it's cool to like
do it for free but you know so you just
need to test and learn everybody's guys
everybody's overthinking just do like I
don't know post rain app like literally
right now as soon as you sit down like
go on [ __ ] whatever platform has the
most go on all of them be like I'm
looking for a video and audio in turn
and see what the [ __ ] happens like again
I always tell people watch what I do not
what I say like you I know a lot of you
knows a good amount of people I see here
that follow me like randomly out of nope
I [ __ ] tweeted today does anybody
make customisable retail floor mats I
need I needed I need like like you do
good do you do them for free and there
states of awareness you know some you
know like like I would ask and then try
somebody and be like you know like the
amount of people I've hired when it was
early in something and I didn't know if
they were good or bad I just thought it
was much smarter to just do it and then
figure it out if it was working and I'm
like oh [ __ ] they sucked
I'm just not scared to waste money or
time and everybody's petrified because
you worry about what other people think
about you that's why if you're curious
that's the [ __ ] answer that's the
[ __ ] that's the [ __ ] answer every
like your answer so easy how do you
build the team hire some [ __ ] people
bro
right but it's like you know but you're
like but I don't understand like people
are scared to get had cuz they don't get
it okay
put in a shitload of time to learn the
craft or bring someone in and watch what
they're doing carefully instead of like
outsourcing it and [ __ ] falling
asleep because you're all [ __ ]
passive income and I got a team doing
[ __ ] and I'm [ __ ] stupid
got it Thanks
yeah hey Gary Jay my name is Jay and I
run the inner changemaker podcast and I
want to ask a question that goes a
little deeper with what you're saying in
terms of sound and you're watching what
you do sure we've noticed that you know
you've launched a couple other podcasts
outside of askgaryvee and within within
my experience mean like the brown paper
bags and paper bags kind of like 65
daily so it three sixty-five and alexis
skill write a briefing excuse me so I've
been doing sub branding in my podcast
yeah because I'm testing to see if
there's traction and I'll spin them out
and creates new pillars okay so I guess
my real question is for content creators
yes started on like one platform for
example I started an interview based
show right there's kind of like you have
you know Q&A show yes if you kind of
have that urge to kind of branch out do
it within the interview show because you
have audience there yeah don't worry
that you may lose a couple people like
right now as I'm sure everybody has seen
for two strategic reasons
out of nowhere I'm talking about a lot
more than I should be about wine right
I'm priming it for a reason there is no
question that there's people unfollowing
me cuz like yo bro I [ __ ] came here
and if I can get pumped up because I
have no [ __ ] juice the [ __ ] are you
trying to sell me actual juice right
like you know like so so but I don't
give a [ __ ] because I'm playing I'm
playing up like a macro game like I
don't want to lose people from it I'm
sad I don't want to I don't want to
disrespect your attention and and know
what you came for but I need to test
something and this is what I have and so
I think it's better off for you to like
try it because one you may hit paydirt
you know one thing a lot of people don't
realize is your
look good but they're disguising the
fact that you've plateaued and you're
tired and so I think you try it within
it and you take the risk of a little
decline for enormous upside because you
can always go back right instead of
starting a whole new thing that's gonna
take energy got it
got it cool appreciate it you're welcome
whatever like your hat bro thank you
appreciate that my name is Prince
I want a company called art of visuals
we have over a million content creators
in 122 countries you said something
earlier about everyone 14 to 22 wants to
be a content creator I absolutely agree
with that and have a tons of those
people in my community the problem is
with there being so many content
creators now how do these content
creators how do they create a business
how do they make money when by thousands
of people doing it for free I think
being better yet you know it guys it's
supply and demand and then once there's
too much supply you have to be the best
and just move on to the next thing
like I bought all the Google AdWords of
every wine term for five cents a click
the day it started that was good
then everybody jumped on and they
started becoming two and three and four
dollar words and became different then I
had to be better than I'd be more crafty
than I had a than what I started doing
is the day the Wine Spectator would come
out with good scores we would buy that
exact wine that exact vintage that
became our new arbitrage for a year or
two before everybody caught up do you
know what when a markets mature you've
got to be better do you think it's good
enough just to be a content creator do
you think no content creators need to
also have products and other things that
they're pushing as well if you're
[ __ ] Steven Spielberg you probably
can end up just being a content creator
but if you're like Sal you know maybe
you've got to consider other revenue
streams you know it's just very basic
business supply and demand prince right
four years ago there are people that
land grabbed they were good and they
were first it's just real estate if you
were the people that bought Malibu
beachfront property first you won
right boys you won you made money but
there's a reason you were the first
it wasn't [ __ ] Malibu yet Prince and
now people buy Malibu beachfront
properties they're just better so all
those kids that like they're gonna
aspire to be the next this they've got a
rude awakening they to be the next this
you've got to be five times better its
evolution when people debate these
athletes versus others yet these
athletes would destroy every athlete
from other generations because they work
out 24/7 now they have data now you know
like it hurts my feelings to them my
childhood kid they would get [ __ ]
destroyed LeBron would step on people's
heads in the 80s like people don't get
it it's just [ __ ] evolution you got
it great hat next time I don't really
have asked for you have listened to us
I mean I've watched your stuff a ton
thanks yeah I just want to say thank you
for giving me permission to pursue my
passion and now do what I love everyday
and spend time with my family and make
things and I I'd be remiss if I didn't
say thank you because I don't know if
I'll ever see you if you ever want to
play bubble hockey I'll destroy you dude
and I know I know that you say that
you'll - I know well first of all I live
here there's a spot right this is Street
I can take you to play listen
listen that's gonna happen now I'm a
winner in Boise Idaho it's so crazy you
see you're funny you're smart you know
me you know that now I'm getting licked
now I'm blacked out and want to destroy
your face but the only you know what's
more interesting though your [ __ ]
Wailers hat is [ __ ] me up because I'm
like I'm like [ __ ] man he's got a
Hartford Whalers hat this team hasn't
been in the league for 20 [ __ ] years
he probably is awesome at bubble hockey
I'm gonna do something for real based on
what you just said I want you to come to
vaynermedia for a day I'll pay for your
flight and the hotel and during and and
during that day will play Bubble hockey
and we'll see what's up
[Applause]
well Gary um
I first want to say thank you to both
you and Russell you two are kind of like
the Jesus of marketing and branding I
come off a bordello country Dominican
Republic and it wasn't for you two I
wouldn't be here so I just want to say
thank you so my question right now is
like what are you doing in other
languages because right now like my main
language is in Spanish and I see like a
blue ocean Russell is always talking
about blue ocean he's right and other
languages ridiculous the blue ocean that
there is marketing fitness whatever you
name it the oceans blue so I want to
know why are you doing cuz I'm going
balls deep into so many so what I've
been doing over the last six months I've
poured an ungodly amount of money into
infrastructure to transcribe all my
content into a ton of languages and paid
distribution in them I'm spending on
going to Singapore which is my second
trip to Asia in the last three months go
to Manly mainland China and genuine
going to India in February I'm spending
an enormous amount of time and I'll
spend millions of dollars next year just
on the transcription and distribution of
the content that I'm natively making in
America in the English language so a
solid amount influence marketing on
language like it's cheap in English in
Spanish is pennies on the buck so it's
super creamy you know again cuz I just
can't cuz I miss them I haven't see you
like I remember when Jerome and I I was
like Jerome you need to go and figure
out who these [ __ ] influencers are in
Mexico because they're like like even in
music right now there's so many like I'm
spending a lot maybe you guys are paying
attention cuz I love hip-hop I'm
spending more time with these artists
like I keep telling them you know like
you need to go down to South America
there's so many artists there that are
really popping you have the leverage cuz
the brand of America I mean they're much
bigger artists than you but your America
so you're automatically bigger than them
yeah I mean it's very I totally agree
well thank you you got it good luck
[Applause]
Gary Killa maddux's dad I want to thank
you personally for your your impact in
his life between you and Russell Brunson
seriously I mean coming from a dad I
there's no way I can repay you just that
the character that you've taught him so
I thank you for that
I have two-part question one you gave
him some advice last time you're with
him about patience I hear you talk about
that a lot and I want to know is that
dad you know can you expound a little
bit more on that and then the I'll wait
to answer that I have one more part
about that right so you know it's super
fun for some of us in a space we're
literally watching your son grow up in I
mean I just saw him like [ __ ] dude
you don't look 14 anymore you know like
you know so you're and now he's hanging
around with all these [ __ ] faces so he's
gonna get into trouble right like like
he's like patience is important because
you know he's got more swag now his
sneaker game is stronger like he's going
into that time of his life where dumb
[ __ ] decisions are gonna be made
because he's making decisions to make
short-term cash because he's trying to
arbitrage you for other things in his
life like why do i preach patience
because it's the only thing that keeps
people away from being straight [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's good thanks alright so
what did your dad do you know you talked
about he I didn't have my dad in my life
like I mean luckily still have my dad my
I didn't know wait that until I started
working a liquor store like my dad left
before I woke up and came home after I
slept like as my fact it's probably
funny how I feel about you guys it's fun
to watch you know because I didn't have
that you know but when my dad did do for
me ironically is because I have that
kind of salesmanship and charisma
I was completely full of [ __ ] like I
would be everything I make fun of subtly
I would be if it wasn't for my dad
because at 1415 I went to that liquor
store and you would walk into what was
called shoppers discount liquors back
there I was 14 years old I'd look 9
you'd walk in and be like do you have
this product and I'm like yeah that we
had because I was already full sales kid
I'm like we have that product but I knew
we made more money on this one I was
like but this one's better I had it it
was phenomenal
14
people are like you had it danced my
dad's store I taste thing I mean I don't
think I took about making [ __ ] up I
don't think I said a real thing once and
so my dad took me and he taught me that
my dad thinks embellishing is straight
lying and he suffocated me over a
three-year period that really changed
the course of my life and I think a lot
of my success comes from I have all the
skill sets of that character but between
being you know old country and really
really my dad really not allowing me to
be that guy so that's what he did for me
and I think that's what you if you know
as a dad you need to just keep watching
him evolve and when he goes into
territories that you think are
historically incorrect not new ideas and
doing new [ __ ] no tried-and-true [ __ ]
human but dynamics that win and lose
that's how you try to guide it yeah one
more if you don't mind I'm sure a lot of
these people probably have kids as well
so like your dad was a powerful
businessman and you you had a lot of
ideas and passion as a young age what
did he do to not like how did he how did
you guys balance that was that decision
of him making you stop sell baseball
cards to come work in the liquor store
was that the right decision would you do
that for your kids I'm only asking out
of curiosity because when I hear that
I'm just very curious it's a tricky one
man first of all we were too insular
family were an immigrant family we
didn't know [ __ ] there was no internet
like we didn't know anything like like
we literally just thought when you turn
14 you go work at the store we were
merchants like right like you know
people like that you know that cliche
story just what it was I'm just I it was
my 14th birthday it was [ __ ] time you
know my d's and f's in school weren't
helping me with any compelling reason
that i could get out of it so you know
as far as how we did it we [ __ ]
fought tooth and I thought for every
inch I had and then I got lucky what
happened was when I came from college my
dad had saved up a lot of money through
these years and started building a dream
house for him and my mom and he took
that year off that was and he was just
not around and that year I took the
business from three to ten million
dollars in sales and that was the end of
the debate
awesome thank you man thanks mother hi
hi my name is Sarah hi Sarah I'm really
enjoying her thank you um I was
wondering in retrospect you've built a
brand around yourself in your niche um
is that what you would recommend looking
forward or rather more of a brand around
a brand I think you I think you have to
do both if you're gonna build it around
yourself because what you're alluding to
is you can get pigeonholed and you live
and die by the person I think a lot of
people forget with me
I built my library first garyvee came
later so it's not like I went to Kayla
brow furrow say yeah I didn't come up
the game has me and so I know how to
build like like I'm seriously it's a
little bit [ __ ] up now I don't think I
could pull it off but I kind of want to
actually you just inspired me Sarah I'm
literally gonna build a 25 million
dollar business in the next three years
that nobody knows is mine just to remind
everybody for myself because I'm weird
like that and I need it like that I
built businesses
now let me promise everybody in this
room one thing fame is the number-one
arbitrage in our society fame is not
snapchat ads not being the first result
on Google Fame full brand awareness is
the number one arbitrage so I've built
my brand as a biz dev machine sure well
I'm glad I can inspire you
and it let me know if you need a goalie
god I might he's got a whaler sad I'm
scared awesome
hi Gary
hey Rachel oh you have a nametag I got
so excited I'm Rachel wow that was like
cool for a second then it wasn't so I'm
the mom of two young daughters they've
got a third on the way and it's awesome
being a parent is obviously quite
challenging as an entrepreneur you talk
a lot about what you were taught through
entrepreneurship through your dad's
mistakes and successes and you've had a
lot of success as an entrepreneur so for
your you have two kids right I do what
are the three main things that you hope
that they get out of life and how are
you going to instill those three
principles into them the biggest reason
I'm obsessed with entrepreneurship is
it's the clearest thing and most obvious
thing to me that allows you to do the
following which is do what you want to
do today right like being like waking up
and being able to do whatever the [ __ ]
you want to do is incredible so the only
thing that I want for my kids like from
that standpoint is the ability to do
what they want to do every day
now what scares me about that is they're
probably gonna have that no matter what
because they're gonna inherent extreme
wealth so much so that I've really been
having feelings I used to make fun of
Warren Buffett and Bill Gates am I
headed like you're gonna donate 99% of
your money until you know it's funny you
talk [ __ ] until you live [ __ ] right now
I'm like [ __ ] I don't want to give these
kids [ __ ] [ __ ] that like because because
rich kids have a huge disadvantage
because when I wanted Sega Genesis in
1989 my mom is like cool go get it right
you know like when I you know when I
wanted to go to a Knicks game
I had to sell baseball cards and [ __ ]
sit in the [ __ ] you know like the
[ __ ] top row [ __ ] Carmelo's coming
over my Hamptons house to play with
Xander like it's [ __ ] up so
I I don't know what but here are the
things I give a [ __ ] about number one
more than anything and I will kill them
murder go to jail they have to be kind
kindness is the most important number
two if I ever see them even inkling even
a innuendo even a subtle little joke of
imposing my and my wife's wealth on
somebody else because they think they're
part of that I'll break their [ __ ]
neck and then number three I will not
raise them in the political correct
environment we live in now they know
there is no such thing as fourth place
trophies or participation prizes
[Applause]
now if they want to be nonprofit you
know look they're gonna look at daddy's
Mountain and I'm like [ __ ] that or they
maybe do what I do you know my dad's
things seem big mine's gonna be a hell
of a lot bigger but like other people
have made it bigger than me and kids
have done this they're gonna look at
that and they're gonna say [ __ ] that I'm
going the other way I'm building schools
in Afghanistan or they're gonna be like
[ __ ] I'm gonna climb that mountain
I'm gonna stick it to big mouths
I don't care I don't need my kids to be
entrepreneurs I just need them to be as
lucky as like my mom
I got D's and F's every immigrant got
good grades in the 80s there's a couple
of people a little older here
there was no entrepreneurship school
good school that was it my mom spit spit
in the faces of all those parents that
made fun of my D's and F's and gave me
air cover to be me and it really [ __ ]
worked out not only for me but the world
became it right if my kids want to paint
in tomato sauce I will back them to the
Earth's end as long as that's really why
they're doing it not because they're
doing something to like run away from so
there's a manager so just blind support
as long as they're kind and the last
thing I wanted to say is I'm gonna buy
the Minnesota Vikings so I'll see you
Super Bowl the owners club no no Super
Bowl jets Vikings 2047 I'll see you
there
[Applause]
my question is about time time so you're
an angel investor and a hundred
companies you have books an 800 person
agency and a family and there's it's
unreal to watch how much content you're
putting out how do you choose between
the thousands of startup pitches you're
getting in the which which interview to
do or which speaking becasue it's just
you so much 100% blind belief in my
intuition you know this in you and
Brandon everyone's hustling right like
eventually you lose right like
eventually time you don't have enough
time to do all the opportunity so you're
crippled by opportunity you just have to
go that route otherwise you're just
gonna spend all your time thinking about
the process of making the best decision
and it's you know and you're gonna waste
being able to do four things which would
have included the two things you've been
debating for the last [ __ ] day so
just the belief in my intuition and then
and then lots of making fun of yourself
this one's a perfect example I have to
I'm like I talk about time my son has a
birthday now cuz he's an August per day
I didn't realize it was like this
Saturday like and I think it actually
came after we booked this but like like
all the money and from this talk is
going into the [ __ ] I was originally
gonna go to Seattle now I have to take a
private plane not to miss the play like
I just [ __ ] it up and the whole day
I'm just complaining to you I'm like I'm
a [ __ ] idiot so like you're not
always gonna make it right like you're
always gonna like play micro-macro but I
think everybody's saying no everybody
sing notice [ __ ] because they think
they're being thoughtful or they're
smart like you know me people are saying
no that aren't even a fancy enough to
say yes yet so I just say yes man a lot
thank you yeah hey hello hello great to
meet you great to meet you to pursue
part name Frank J how are you Frank
very good thank you and I want to
appreciate you and your dedication your
consistency and your communication we
own a company called international tribe
design where we bring a style of
communication which is very simple but
yet rare in the society which is
honesty and authenticity and I feel like
you embody this and I feel like a lot of
us entrepreneurs well at least for me it
was like shall I present myself
strategically or authentically yeah and
what I want to ask you is the first by
the question what do you think sells
more or influence more people authentic
honesty or strategic marketing near
linguistic programming communication I
think in the short term it's a real
battle I think either could win I think
in the 30-year macro the radical candor
authentic way always wins mm-hmm what do
you know what I mean
yeah and the thing that [ __ ] with
people is a lot of people can win on
strategic you're being very politically
correct like a lot of people can win on
[ __ ]
play it out for four years get out of
the game with their chips and win not a
lot of people can though but then once
you know of one of those examples it
sounds exciting cuz it's a fuckload
easier huh what do you think the future
is for collaboration first competition
so what we're all about is collaboration
let's bring us all together I think we
can all do great things I think I think
both will work right the competition
matters right like I want to destroy a
[ __ ] whale or hat I want to kill I
want to kill Vikings girl like you know
like like competition matters right like
I'm not gonna like like xeni miss
all-out but I'll tell you like in real
life Drogo five let's just put it even
in black and white Drogo five David
droga phenomenal businessman has an
incredible agency he's gonna get his let
me tell you one thing that a lot of you
are making mistakes cuz you're saying
[ __ ] behind people's backs
you can't stop winners from winning
winners win so something I don't
remember when it became obvious to me
but it's unbelievable if I see a winner
I'm like she's a winner it's binary
even if she's taking David droga winning
in my world alongside vaynermedia right
I'm pumped I'm happy for him because if
you're also a winner you're gonna always
eat winners win a lot of people see
somebody as a winner and there
there yet or they feel like they're
taking away from them and they're
talking [ __ ] and really all that's doing
is exposing where you're at like it's
unbelievable when you know I hang out
with a lot of people you know like
people start yapping a little like I'm
like winners win right and so unless
you're doing something really not Noble
or things of that nature winners win and
so I think that I collaborate with other
winners who take from me complex and you
know vice and these are women they're
gonna win yeah not you not gonna stop a
winner and so keep that in mind I think
that's something that does hold back
this competitive driven hungry demo more
than you might realize
Envy is stupid it's just not practical
it just I just don't spend any time but
like why hey Rob Gary great to be here
with you man seriously a lot it's been
about three years since I've been I you
came across my facebook feed you were
talking to some millennial kid and you
just owned him you just had me hooked
from that moment but a couple things I
so you totally I apologize I'm I'm
really anti the downplay of like
millennial kids like and I don't think
that's what you're doing but I just
figured I'd put it on film like like I'm
42 there was plenty of lazy losers
entitled [ __ ] when I was 22 to like
this notion that gladioli Millennials
are first and foremost dramatically
better human beings than the other
generation it's actually not even close
and you can't be mad at them the market
this has nothing to do with Millennials
and over parenting this has to do with
economics the last nine years have been
phenomenal we haven't had a crash how
many people here are under 29 raise your
hand you've never tasted the game when
it was hard
you've never been punched directly in
the [ __ ] mouth yet
you don't wake up like I did in April
2000 and the market collapse at every
invoice that every order is over you
don't know what it feels like when the
corporations that want to give you
$10,000 for a selfie don't spend money
anymore it's a little harder to be an
influencer when there's no cash in the
system so I'm not mad at Millennials a
mad at people's not understanding of why
you know they're awesome human beings
because they're far more well-rounded
and they just had a good and that's not
their fault we could have had that I got
into the world in New Jersey mm got [ __ ]
on 911 got [ __ ] on 2007 got [ __ ] on so
I've tasted that so just keep that in
mind and by the way the reason I told
that story is please keep in mind that
the economy has been phenomenal for the
last nine years like a lot of the good
is coming for you
because of what's happening at a macro
level you're just average I'm being
serious and I'm not saying that to razz
I'm saying that to make you reflect so
that you can step up your game so that
when the [ __ ] ravage comes you don't
die so good you got a little zing that
your average but now you can actually
stay alive and not go work a [ __ ] go
back to business school sorry bro
didn't know that was gonna take you down
that course but so you talk about how
companies are kind of behind the
eight-ball on on the whole social media
Facebook marketing it's how it's it's a
good value right now do you see are you
starting to see that trend diminish and
and when do you see you know that being
not a value Facebook as soon as math
against and art combined to not be
valuable like on television meanwhile
Super Bowl is the best that anybody here
it's got 20 million thrown around run a
super wide this year the problem is
there seven it's only seven for the ad
which is phenomenal but the network
makes you buy some other [ __ ] that's
where it gets [ __ ] up but Super Bowl
is an incredible value
I don't know I'm stunned that these big
companies that I work with still
question its ROI and want to run
commercials and billboards it's it's so
fun to watch them all go out of business
over the next 20 years they deserve it
I can't wait seriously last thing is you
mentioned political correctness and your
kids which is awesome and I think that's
what everyone loves about you is you
just say what's on your mind and I think
we can all take a page out of that book
of just being sure honest you with this
crazy climate of you know the whole you
know the Google guy that got you know
fired from there the whole ESPN thing
like how do you how do you see this
political correctness and what do you do
to to mitigate that in your company
so it's a really good question Rob and
it's a really tough one couple things
number one said something the other day
that finally articulated how I feel
about all of it
which is I said to friend like [ __ ]
people so there's only one place in my
life where I'm not logical or practical
American football right like against all
data I think that you know the Patriots
are cheaters and and Bill Belichick's a
terrible guy and even though Tom Brady's
like clearly and I'd like to literally
spent money on investigative journalism
he's the nicest human being ever
I still say things like yeah he left his
pregnant wife for Gisele he's a piece of
[ __ ] like I will do anything blindly I
I've chemical like even talking right
now the chemicals in my body are
different I feel it I hate them so much
I I really I really want Bill Belichick
to die like I don't even I don't you
know it's funny I wonder if people think
like I'm going for Schlick I want it so
cool we've established that right I'm
clearly irrational over emotional not
logical and just the worst version of
myself in that one narrow place if you I
mean there are people who are fans of me
who've DME or have tweeted that I'm a
bad I mean I yell at children I'm a
games I'm I'm not joking you know how
people get beer muscles you know that
term you drink and you want to fight I
have sports muscles like I go to a game
and even though everybody would probably
be able to beat me up I want to fight
you because it feels better than feeling
the pain of your team beating mine right
like a week ago I realized holy [ __ ]
that's how blindly everybody is now
about politics
you're either red or blue and you
deployed no logic no rationale you are
blindly emotional you've no idea what
the [ __ ] you're talking about and that's
it
you know we're about to turn every issue
and to applet how the [ __ ] is climate a
political like what are we doing here so
I have a huge office in New York in LA
84% of my employees are liberals 84
right
so I have liberal points of view all day
long the thought of hating anybody or
disliking another human being for any
reason other than maybe being a patriot
is insane to me insane to me insane to
me but I have clearly you know
Republican put like an eighth place
trophy is why China is gonna [ __ ] on us
with such a big [ __ ] dump that we'll
never be able to breathe again how I
handle it is by one by one one by one
it's very hot you cannot handle this
at a macro right now because our
society's on tilt I'm so [ __ ] pissed
I was born in [ __ ] Russia I would
[ __ ] run went easy and [ __ ]
dominate really would I'd really feel
like I could do it Josh
Garin the airport man yeah absolutely
Thanks
I want my influence from marketing yeah
youtubers vloggers instagramers a lot of
people are talking about Facebook as
Instagram and snapchat ads ROI we can't
measure our alonissos
it's you can measure with influencers
too you can but it takes a lot longer
doesn't Hausa
you've got to make the creative be a
sales creative instead of a brand
creative you can't measure the ROI of
Facebook either when you do it the way I
do it cuz I'm pumping it for brand I'm
not trying to sell you [ __ ] I can
measure it if I had a $49 course so how
much people are confused between
branding and selling make [ __ ]
phenomenal and [ __ ] influencers go
for the sale in the creative if they
choose to and you can afford them Logan
Paul sold a fuckload of Dunkin Donuts
[ __ ] gift cards sales super [ __ ]
measurable Josh so would you focus like
let's pretend you're not Gary Vaynerchuk
right let's take you out of the equation
you are ma'am I you're you are a 41 year
old 42 41 still 41 41 0 you're a 41 year
old nobody right you have say a million
dollars of invest
behind you then you're definitely not
nobody feel bad but let's just look
contact [ __ ] Joshy alright fine fine
you're gonna look at what your old
nobody yeah you're getting a game right
yeah well you focus on growing your
personal brand or would you focus on
leveraging other people's personal
brands that don't already think so you
would you would you ride the backs of
using the people that you're building
like that you're investing in and roar
yeah okay
like if you're trying to are you asking
let's Josh huh what are you asking I'll
give you the answer you're trying to
build your personal brand I am trying to
put my personal brand actually yeah
absolutely
are you thinking about I want to build
my personal brand in a different niche
than the influencers that I want to
invest in understood I think that is
long understand this just because they
may be in a different niche they have so
much awareness that the people that
watch them may will be into other things
got it yep so if it's a good deal on
awareness you might be able to convert
and then your product has to be good
cool do you know what I mean yeah like
that's the math you're looking at you
don't have to use the targeted nature of
the ads if the influencers a better deal
even though you might lose 85% of the
audience because that's not why they're
watching them but they're still gonna
get 15% of opportunity and then the
whole [ __ ] kit and caboodle is are
you good enough all right one last
question
um I I'm a die-hard diehard Patriots fan
if if Tom Brady makes it to Super Bowl
this year will you go to the Super Bowl
with me on me no no I'm not only that
I've been to the last six Super Bowls
they've been there two or three times
you know and I'm now with Boehner Sports
and Steve Ralston or dolphins my
business partners I go and the owners
dinner it's all fun the last two Super
Bowls two of the last three Super Bowls
I left the city Sunday more I've not
watched the Patriots play a down of a
Super Bowl game in the last four Super
Bowls that they played in because I
refused
everybody's like the greatest comeback
in a Super Bowl I'm good I have no idea
what the [ __ ] you guys are talking about
I didn't see [ __ ]
well you like winners and I'd like to
invite you to the winning team no no
Josh Josh you're confused my friend I'm
a winner you root for winners dick be
careful that by the way you just
witnessed my favorite move Knicks heat
game seven years ago dude walks by beer
remember sports muscles guys I get up
I'm like you [ __ ] suck sit the [ __ ]
down
I mean I get weird you said he looks at
me goes yeah we suck look at the
scoreboard [ __ ] I go not then you
[ __ ] you suck by the way the darkest
version of what you just saw and Josh
knows I love him but the darkest version
I go to Foxborough for every game we
always get [ __ ] on around the third
fourth quarter when I'm really getting
[ __ ] on because I bring my jetski I'm
[ __ ] running in their proper right
somewhere around the fourth quarter when
I'm getting [ __ ] on I change the
conversation I'm like look Zann I'm
super pumped that your entire self
esteem is wrapped into your football
team because you work at Pizza Hut and
so [ __ ] you my life's better than yours
maybe your football team is better than
mine but I'm better than you zan Jared
hey so going back a little bit you
talked about intuition right and belief
in your intuition yes
I'm a two day I idea guy right idea and
then me to me after two days I'm like
like a seven that you let to write more
right Nicole like eight that like he
bothers the [ __ ] out of you right yeah
he's like what about a drone ice-cream
company go ahead that's a so how do you
develop that intuition and how do you
like support and strengthen your belief
in your own intuition to my ass light by
acting on some of them the biggest
problem is especially when you have like
people around you is like you want to be
right right like it's much better than
getting made fun of for being wrong
consistently but like by [ __ ] picking
like just by try to do stuff everything
you know everyone's like oh you you're
always in it like
doing like just try and [ __ ] like nobody
talks about the stuff that I'm doing
that guys nobody remembers the part
where Michael Jordan couldn't get to the
finals because the Pistons were beating
him every single time you know what I
mean guys let me really unleash you
doing more [ __ ] nobody remembers the
losses as long as you have a win and you
know like listen some of you know my
stuff and like I'm starting to like
figure out my own stuff it comes down to
six people your mom your dad your
siblings your loved ones you're doing so
much [ __ ] based on their points of view
on stuff you can't even imagine
you can unwind that you're off to the
races it scares me how much I value my
wife and parents opinion and how much I
don't at all and in that balance I win
at a macro I value them but on a micro
my decisions not at all you know Jared
so you just got a do one or two of them
you go you go one four seven it's a lot
better than going 204 oh yeah thank you
you got last question yeah sign it yeah
100%
hi let's do it
well I'm signing what's your question
Katie hi Gary I'm Katie Richardson and I
was first introduced to you as I was
trying to go to bed at night and my
husband's got his phone on and I'm
hearing this guy make a rant in a cab
throwing throwing f-bombs in the other
word I'm like what the heck is this and
turns out you speak tons of truth and so
you have won over this mother of four
who's a business owner and I love it and
so that's kind of what my question to
you is is like you own who you are and I
love that and like that's what people
are so attracted to right and proceed
you're up there being Gary at what point
like you talked about how you worked
with your dad and it was a three million
dollar company then you took it a ten
million after he left at what point did
you like give yourself permission to be
you and then realize like tell us that
story but when you are like wow this is
working people are connecting with me
and my way of being and like what was
that like when you were like this is
working I feel like I'm gonna keep doing
this you know it's funny
there's thank you first of all there's a
lot of things there number one it is
100% because of nature-nurture being an
immigrant and always having a chip in
your shoulder you're always an outcast
to begin with at some level and I was a
Russian immigrant which was our major
enemy when I was a kid so I had some
weird [ __ ] going on that I tell a whole
lot cuz it's not as relevant these days
but there's a lot of parallels to
whoever the bad guys are now I was the
bad guy she's kind of weird for a little
while number two my mom came a mom lied
like I remember walking sophomore year
in high school no freshman year in high
school I'm 4 foot 11 my freshman year
high school I spurred it in sophomore
year I'm well I have the worst [ __ ]
mullet you've ever seen in your life
I've got a backpack that I'm rolling
with that's bigger than me and I'm
walking down the hall and I go I
remember I remember as vividly I'm like
wait a minute I'm not the best-looking
awesomest dude in the world like my mom
had me so brainwashed I'm being serious
on straight positivity that like that
never went away like my mom if I open
the door for a woman like my mom was
super smart I'm doing the same thing she
would make if I opened the door this is
a true story Kati I opened the door for
a woman when I was 9 at McDonald's but
that's the story I went to McDonald's
woman was coming I held the door open
for her my mom reacted as if I won the
[ __ ] Nobel Peace Prize
and she did that about all the [ __ ] that
matters which is what makes me who I am
today
fourth-grade Katie fourth grade I got an
F in a science test I needed to get it
signed cuz I guess that's how they used
to do it I don't know if they still do
that [ __ ] I flushed it down the toilet
because my dad hadn't gotten to me yet
and and and then like I was like but I
was still a kid so my conscious was
still around and so I just couldn't
sleep and I told my mom and basically
three weeks later I was sitting in
social studies fourth grade and said
[ __ ] this I'm out and from that day on I
decided to fail every class work on my
business skills and become who I'm gonna
be I love it thank you you're welcome
right it's my second time sorry sorry
Brett yeah I just had a quick ask I make
amazing baby products and I don't know
if you're still having babies or not but
if you need like the awesomest baby gift
for a friend come to me my company's
called Pudge like baby Pudge sent me an
email to Gary a banner media okay in the
title right our entire story I was the
one with the four kids okay the husband
and the bed and you won me over yeah
Pudge and this all of it awesome and
then we'll interact
yeah I'll make you look amazing as a
gift giver thank you you're welcome
Bret it's my second time seeing you and
it's funny how a different energy of
different audiences like the first time
I went you were like you even told the
audience I am NOT excited to be here I
looked at your stuff it sucks and and
the lady had been like talking about
coaching the whole time then you're like
don't do it just do stuff anyways it was
awesome it was it was just a couple of
months ago in Provo but it was funny um
but anyways quick side question was like
do you sense different energy and
audience a hundred percent okay because
it's like it is this thing I own I have
my religions and my beliefs then I have
my craft so I'm doing everything
state-of-the-art right so I have my
thesis 'iz then I have my work I was in
Seattle yesterday I spent nine hours
understand the boys space loved my craft
my craft so I have my thesis is Brett I
have my craft and my the reason I'm
doing well in speaking is
I take my thesis 'as I take my craft
which sometimes has some nuances that
are valuable right usually always ahead
of the market and then I reverse
engineer the actual audience I reverse
engineer the audience like what I give a
lot of thought and speak to the people
that organize who are you where are you
in your funnel of life and like what can
I bring to the most general and how
quick can I get to Q&A so that whatever
I miss in the general we can get to in
the details I totally agree because it's
just a different energy but I feel this
time versus last time but my big
question is please you think of like
levar ball or yes Kim Kardashian or even
Donald Trump for that matter like I can
culture yeah like what are your thoughts
on them and like is that the kind of
Fame you want there's that the comment
you talked about Fame being the biggest
arbitrage what are your thoughts on
those kind of people so there's a really
interesting thing that I believe in
which is until you know somebody you
don't know somebody right and so like
look I mean getting political never
works but like you know Trump's got his
shtick right and the like he won on my
thesis for the last ten years right Kim
Kardashian literally is like like we are
all living in reality TV people [ __ ] on
reality TV in Hollywood then a [ __ ] on
influencers they're all gonna pay
because if you're not abiding to what
the consumer wants you will always lose
it doesn't matter what you want on your
ivory tower it matters what the world is
consuming but I don't to be very very
very frank I don't think about it a
whole lot right I know why they're
winning
they were native DJ Khaled is an
unbelievably important case study in the
in the last 10 years and the next 10
years his personality was native to a
platform at the right time in the right
moment and he disproportionately changed
his career on that back Kim Kardashian
Donald Trump navigated reality TV when
reality TV was what social media has
been for last four years somebody here's
gonna get inspired and make a voice
application for their business that will
be that for when voice is here in two
years for the next six years from
22 2026 it's literally the same game
over and over Brett so I want what I
want
listen Fame and exposure you know like
it doesn't change you it exposes who you
are so I don't know how you personally
judge those three and everybody here
judges those three differently I just
want to be known for what I am and who I
am and how I roll
appreciate that thank you you got it hey
how are you um I'm here with my amazing
husband Josh who's like my backbone an
amazing business partner I'm a little
googly talking to you because I remember
meeting Justin Timberlake when I was 14
but you're like my 30 Tyrael Backstreet
Boys
he was an NSYNC oh yeah I loved them all
but I love you more for the past seven
years you've given me the ability to be
really authentic I'm in a niche for it's
very Club promoting okay so network
marketing yep so I basically for the
last seven years have sold my soul to
direct selling companies and they made a
lot of money and have built an
incredible following of network
marketers and direct sellers and now
that I've built a great team that's
passive and I serve them and I love them
but I really want to branch out into
more mainstream impact primarily to
female entrepreneurs and I want to know
what's your recommendation for somebody
like news had this huge niche they all
expect me to be the prospect or the
close of the lead generator the team
builder just now to say all right
imagine if we had coffee I'm gonna give
you the 90 percent answer because
there's 10 percent that's too personal I
don't want to do it here you will net
you have to I have to figure out how
mainstream you want to be I'll buy you
coffee
I'm sure
I don't know how mainstream you want to
be so like if you want to be mainstream
like the cover of Forbes and like like
mainstream like all the way mainstream
you'll have to give up network marketing
yeah completely and I have no problem
with whatever God has for me I just no I
mean that's it's a stunningly binary
answer Rach Christ if you know if you
want to go mainstream you have to give
it up because it is a what's that stigma
a hundred percent yeah and I'm the math
around how many people make money and
how many don't correct my last question
is is there any trends that you see or
platforms or any advice that you see
with women entrepreneurs primarily my
age thirties forties
yes so the thing you know it's funny
Katie right um
hey Katie said the most important part
I've become unbelievably fascinated and
empathetic about the difference between
men and women you know I'm super
fascinated by it from a business
standpoint that's my lens to the world
it's harder to be 100% yourself when
you're a woman that a man I genuinely
believe that because men are dick faces
right and so the answer to your question
is to be 100% radically transparently
you I'm also massively empathetic how
that's difficult for everybody
especially attractive women but that's
the answer
thank you got it what's up man so I've
been good man so four years ago I was
couch surfing and living out of my car
and I sat in a room with Gary and
thirteen you know they're 13 other kids
and Gary told us that this app was going
to change our lives forever and it did
and Gary was such a positive change on
my life now unfortunately they deleted
the app what
yeah [ __ ] that's amazing actually I just
wanted to make that joke but but I I
knew wouldn't but but her real question
real question for you when you run into
your failures and yes you're like you're
at your rock bottom yes what's your next
move because I'm always trying to
reinvent myself yep and I'll do things
that work and then I'll do things that
don't you you and some of your friends
are the table you guys have a big
advantage and all of you have gone a
little bit different with that
transition of mine and what happened on
snapchat and Instagram and things that
nature but you've something very special
first of all you've talent right second
of all you've once tasted what it's like
to buy beachfront property in Malibu no
I know what I mean yeah aka
you knew what it meant to your career by
being one of the first 40 people that
mattered on a platform that became fresh
right yeah instead of trying to what you
and others that have by the way you know
why I wish you could see the goosebumps
I have right now it happened to me I won
Twitter and then you know I then I
wasn't at the top of stuff like I was in
that 2006 7 and 8 world you know right
why do you think the vine thing and this
is where I'm going with this it's you
basically if you choose to it's gonna
happen again
and let me explain why the reason I got
you guys all together and I flew to LA
and met with others of you like the
reason I did that was it was black and
white I'm like I [ __ ] seen this show
before right and like yeah you said that
you actually said that you were like
saying this is the new YouTube it just
was so black in November and obviously
it took different tacks and the ones
that kind of tripled down on Instagram
had what happened happened
but you instead of trying to catch up to
what's now I give you the recommendation
that I took myself because I tend to
only give advice that I've actually done
because it just feels better you got it
you got it
either hibernate make do grind through
and spend all your time looking for that
next one that is one that you should be
downloading you you should be down at
you you should be downloading a top 100
app in the Apple Store that is social or
consumer facing every day
your life creating an account and
producing the first piece of content
okay I might do that awesome
you got a brother fellow 411 freshmen
here I love it a really quick question
made a little personal you know we have
this engine all of us in this room have
this engine we can't we have a hard time
shutting off it makes us successful how
do you how do you balance work and
family how do you do it by first and
foremost not adhering to the current
state of political correctness that
everybody here is deployed on me most of
all right and second extremism I almost
took the whole entire month of August
off like I go all in right I go when I'm
in this like Monday through Friday I do
not see my kids pretty much at all 39
weeks of the 52 weeks in a year just
what it is and then on weekends and you
know seven weeks eight weeks of vacation
a year I'm all in the other way that's
how I do it for me but that is only
uniquely gonna work if me and my partner
in crime are aligned on that strategy
audit that strategy every day by the way
I don't even want to do it anymore
as now they're eight and five and not
five and two they're just more
interesting to be around you know so so
like for example I guarantee you in 24
more months this exact trip they're here
and we go to you know we go and see the
Grand Canyon or something you know so
like like you know I um I'm so sad that
so many people do certain things in
parenting because that's what the other
parents think they should be doing like
I don't know like I just want to make a
very important statement that I implore
every pair in this room understands
everything that is right in parenting
right now by the common standards will
not be in 20 years you're gonna be
judged one way or the other so thanks
you got a brother
Gary over here oh hey hey how are you
good
fellow 42 year old I think your mom and
my mom should hang out bro cuz that
think similar stuff a mom's yeah she
sounds amazing
and then uh just want to let you know
like validation on the sound totally
true cuz I like literally take a shower
with you every morning so thanks brother
dude I just play it I got a little
shower thing I listen to your audio I
get it gets me going so thank you that
visual is [ __ ] awesome I didn't even
think about you seeing the visual but
not I think about yeah that's good a
different way thank you so I got a
two-part question for you one is on
culture so our our company is grown and
now we're we're doing pretty well and
I'm you've been to like nine figures and
that's where we want to go right so my
first question is okay from a culture
standpoint when you grow rapidly how do
you embed the culture and to make sure
that it grows with the right people
right so we built values manifestos
ready yeah how do you get muscles by
doing push-ups you do it consistently
every day I spend an ungodly amount of
my time on HR like now I have 800 police
the biggest thing I'm working on for
2018 so I have an open-door policy which
is not working for me it's real
open-door like the key big thing for my
two admins and assistants is when an
employee ask they get booked whoever
first day nine years done not working
they think I'm fancy and garyvee they're
scared nobody wants to really talk to
their CEO so next year I'm gonna mandate
that I see every one of my employees
every six months for 15 minutes which is
gonna eat up big amounts of time culture
is the only thing you trade on so you're
gonna see all eight hundred employees 15
minutes yes do I see you
okay so literally a Nick you know wanna
is daunting when I do the one-on-one
time it always works but I'm just
thinking that from scale at standpoint
like how the heck scaling the unscalable
is how you build long term wealth damn
dude that's good one
thanks
any I didn't get up here from [ __ ] now
we know how you get paid to stand up
second my second question was okay as
you grow obviously have things you get
you've got haters right I'm sure that
people don't like you and whatever sure
so I always focus on the mission and the
vision and the people that we're helping
right but when you get like certain
people I mean still effects like me like
so how do you overcome that so you can
keep growing empathy for them yes and
like just with their life circumstances
or sure if a human being can generate
hate they're not a good place okay so
what do you do
mentally and mindset to just keep going
I deployed gratitude that oh not them
okay got it
thanks man thank you hey man so I
started on - all doing like yeah and now
I do it on Instagram and I grew a large
following on their various branches yeah
and it's so growing a lot but I want to
be ahead as you saying I know I have a
lot of meetings about VR yes and
creating content with NVR I'm a very
anti consumer VR guy in the in the
timing that I like so everything for me
is 24 36 months yeah right I just don't
know how many people are consuming at
the scale that you would be giving up
opportunity costs in other places in 36
months of yarn until I see even one
person consistently consuming VR like an
hour a week like if I can find one human
who's not a [ __ ] really weird nerd
who spends one hour right so I think the
reason you're feeling that is in you're
in the LA bubble
everybody's pumping a ton of money from
venture capital into VR and it's
literally I don't know like I mean the
thing you should study is what happened
to the web in 99 mm yeah the hole you've
probably seen a pets calm all these
companies worth or drill Ian that's what
I feel about VR it's coming amazon's
coming
right eBay scumming but I think for you
and knowing the arbitrage that you can
trade on
I don't believe like if I was talking to
you every week I'd be like that's not a
good place to be spending your energy
okay that's my intuition yeah I do think
voice is incredible and then I think for
you specifically cuz I know enough from
afar we don't know each other super well
but I know a lot from afar you might
want to think about what you want to put
that energy into what bucket that's why
it's good that you're here right what I
do think these guys do that's sales and
quant like or if it's you know a brand
or an event or you're gonna be able to
push that energy towards something you
need to take a step back and get
thoughtful with yourself on like what
other interests you have or you know
that that wouldn't come natural as the
first thing you would think like the
five or six things you think of health
and wellness and lifestyle it's
interesting it's probably something
subtle putting your energy into building
in that world if you want to really
double down on entrepreneurship is a
good idea
you're welcome all right guys we have
time for only three more questions so
we'll go miles over there and then we
have to hear and that'll be it Charles
get up there will do for your face
challenges yeah and I like understanding
other people's processes so my question
to you is what is your number one
business challenge right now and what is
your process to come up with that
solution I'm crippled by opportunity is
my number one business problem and it's
similar to what I gave over there I'm
I'm just attacking it with blind
intuition I every time me and my team
try to attack it from a quant standpoint
it's too foreign it's moving too fast on
us and so that's it man crippled by
opportunity which is a blessing in a
[ __ ] half as you can imagine but it's
the truth
you know it's the truth like do I say
yes to a second season of plan of the
apps do I like do I mean the nixar for
sale it's like running through my mind
you know like like there's just a lot
there's a lot going on man
going on right but I mean it other than
intuition I mean I get imagine that
there's a bottleneck in terms of
leverage
where's my China yeah I mean intuitions
the solve for the bottleneck which is
making decisions in deploying my
energies against those decisions y'all
leaving everything else on the side you
know I decided here ago I was raising
150 million dollar fund I gave all the
money back I lost it was the biggest
financial loss of my career because I
hired the staff and I was gonna pay the
staff but the 2% if you know venture of
you know the overall fund that I was
gonna rate how much 150 million dollars
on that's a lot of money 2% I had a
pretty expensive staff I was going
through the process and I'd raised about
80 million dollars and one night I'm
flying home and I'm like I don't believe
in this I don't want to spend this 150
million dollars on startups I think
there's too much fake [ __ ] in the market
I don't know where to deploy it I think
I'm gonna lose it and I gave it all back
right
that's intuition thought process
understanding you know so I'm just doing
that everyday awesome it's like you got
it no big fan man but my girlfriend is
an even bigger fan and I basically
couldn't live down the shame of not
asking a question I love it so I'm a
social media manager and I would just
love to hear about what you think is the
best campaign you've ever ran and why do
you qualify it that way
sour patch kids candy we made it a
cultural phenomenon because we gave we
took all the money from television
commercials which go figure 12 to 15
year olds don't watch and we gave it to
all the people that sit at that table or
the ones that look like them we took in
four and a half years ago we took Sour
Patch Kids marketing budget and put into
snapchat and Instagram when nobody was
thinking that way and if anybody has a 9
to 17 year old in her life they eat sour
patch kids awesome thanks oh my god
and Sabrina answered a question the
reason I quantify it that way wasn't
there's been campaigns that we've done
that have made more money have you know
gotten excuse me may more likes or
awareness or more views you know he he
stands up here and he goes thanks to
everybody we have a hundred thousand
use I already know him enough to know
yeah and what's what what's happening
with those views you know a lot of
people in social media they plan vanity
metrics not sales the sour patch kids is
the answer because we have had campaigns
get more of you this Budweiser Derek
Jeter and Harry Kalas stuff we're doing
for Budweiser's insane we've really
crushed sales we're changing a tough
brand in the US but sour patch kids
became the fastest-growing candy in 20
years over here real fast
oh okay noise hey Linds hi so I'm a
course creator yes I also help
entrepreneurs teach better so there's
things get better results I'm a little
bit at a crossroads I heard you talking
about being in a space that's a little
over something right and so of course
creation is a little that right of
course I see though the chance to make
better teachers to make their products
better good that's one thing good and I
think I could do really well they're
great but I'm also around the
opportunity of I'm a past tenure track
professor and I left academia okay and
as I was leaving fellow professors were
like you figured it out let go I also
feel a calling to help professors kind
of do what I do
you should definitely so that's get out
of me no no I've great news but this is
easier like helping entrepreneurs is so
easy okay
no [ __ ] Linds I know but this is back to
that Kevin quite like it like you got to
decide what you like by the way I have a
crazy thing to tell you based on
something I've been looking at please
tell me the professors are about to
become easier I know cuz they're all
about to go out of business
there no it's a thinking [ __ ] yes but
once guess what this is the thing I
wrote about in crushing I said all these
newspapers and magazines are in deep
[ __ ] it's that the writers are gonna be
better not worse they think that I mean
these professors are about to get the
money they deserve yes and then there's
Lindsay at peatlands eat [ __ ] for 36
months leave money on the table that was
easy from the entrepreneurs that are
never gonna make it and go help what
faster move start I mean your first move
is to build the business
sure like what's the business that you
want to do do you want to be TED
conferences do you want to be a course
do you want to teach one on one do you
want to sell a product I mean what you
need to decide what I want to help them
plan an exit strategy and to realize
that there's actually money that there's
a lot of professors that could probably
make courses really good that's what I
do yeah okay so charge like charge them
money for your knowledge if that's what
you want to do okay and you know you can
put that in seven different buckets yeah
right I'm telling you right now you're
walking right into the one of what is
going to be an enormous large space and
the fact that you were one of them do
you know how much I kill with small
businesses yeah
not because it's funny and haha it's cuz
I was one of them yeah thank you you're
welcome
hey Gary I'm Kailyn Thank You Lee this
is crazy to like literally be
face-to-face to see right now so thank
you so much for answering my question um
one of the reasons that I love you so
much and love following you so much is I
really resonate with the whole
chip-on-the-shoulder thing yeah that's
that's what drives everything that I do
I grew up super poor at least standing
here with all these people right now is
just insanely surreal right and you want
to kill them right I don't want to kill
them I want to like work with all of you
and I just hit me up please
but this thing that's happened is I'm I
feel like an entrepreneur on accident
honestly okay and the things that I love
to do is is the business that I do
that's making you money but recently
I've started being like way more
vulnerable about the whole
chip-on-the-shoulder thing and like in
telling my story and that's resonating
with a lot of people but that's [ __ ]
hard like I hate doing that because I'm
very introverted I don't like being out
there that much but that's what seems to
be making the biggest impact my dreams
what's binary either you do more of it
and you get used to it and like
everything in life once you get used to
it it just becomes your norm and you
didn't realize it now you may never be
the most extroverted but you just
expected everybody here can be a better
singer dancer and basketball player they
may not become LeBron but if you do it
every day you get better you keep
putting yourself out there every day
you'll get better
you can either choose to do that or you
could say I don't like it I'll leave the
money on the table because I love the
privacy in the private life and not
having to engage and you do that it's
your choice
you're in charge are you an advocate for
doing like what's harder though I'm an
advocate I'm doing on doing what you
want to do not because I said so or your
friend said so it's I'm an advocate of
you doing what you want to be doing but
I always encourage to taste more cuz it
works any people here you know me people
here hate oysters but I've never had one
I think about that [ __ ] every day
that's how I think about business like
you've made a judgment on something yet
you've never done it so um you know you
know what I'm gonna say you know you've
like consumed it the fact I mean I
already know you're gonna do more of it
because you've already done the hardest
part which is you've done it you're now
a foregone conclusion to me KP you're
just gonna keep doing it you know like
that's what you're gonna do okay you're
just looking for me to give you a little
more juice to do it a little bit more a
little bit more a little bit more which
is amazing and I'm thrilled to do it cuz
it's [ __ ] for you here you go go
thank you you're welcome
just really quickly is there anything
that is hard for you like I know I know
like your mindset the way that you think
about things you're like I am confident
I can do this but like is yes it hard
yes like get up in the morning sometimes
no if anything no part it's at all okay
spelling is [ __ ] impossible
I can't read for [ __ ] uh if I was
reading from a teleprompter right now I
would crumble and be out of here can't
read for [ __ ] like you know fencing
probably hard oh I'm really way below
average and swimming poor swimmer like
always think like [ __ ] I'll be super
pissed if I like that's out if I die
because we get [ __ ] uh like somebody
hits a tree and I first have to swim
further than everybody and like like the
other [ __ ] you know with you know why
you ask that question
validation no it's the because what know
why you asked me of that question
validation the first part the second
part you're asking me that
as somebody who knows a lot about me
because I don't spend any time on it we
all suck at [ __ ] so like I don't care
how you judge mine you got [ __ ] too
so because I don't care about that I'm
the only reason people spend time on
their weaknesses is because it's
everybody else's opinion on it that
they're trying to avoid I don't care
about your opinion about my weakness cuz
I know you've got them too so let's just
move on thank you so much can we get a
photo with you and you're done yes thank
you
hey Charles hey Gary
if you ever swim a lot so I'm 37 so I'm
not you know where you are at age wise
but you know I've been lucky a few times
in life and you know I've done well and
done that so well and everything and I
have done well I guess my question is
you know it's always the concept of the
encore right you know when my one
company you know I've had eight digit
companies before and now I'm watching
another one and I guess it's like how do
you get into it make bets on it but feel
accomplished if you don't outdo your
last time because I don't I do not even
remotely think that the financial part
is the way I score it mm-hmm
you know what I mean I mean that's
really simple like out doing the last
one is you know even the way you
precision listen to your words you're
positioning it like if you're putting
pressure on
I need a Niner right mm-hmm then you're
then you're probably gonna specially you
know it's funny about positioning a
Niner when you've had an eider it's hard
to get going that's the that's probably
the channel I know exactly what's going
on with you Charles yeah and so that's
why I'm asking you are you doing the
ambition of a 9 or 10 or because you see
the white space and you're gonna strike
like a [ __ ] Cobra or is it cuz you
really just want to [ __ ] do it
so let me give me an example what I've
been doing for the last seven years I
don't love it client services like
having a 32 year old brand manager from
the University of Chicago telling me
what she should do with Captain Crunch
when she can't sell [ __ ] I'm actually
from the USA so great yeah so like not
fun for me yeah but I know why I'm doing
it I decided at 35 36 that I was gonna
spend 10 years of my prime as a business
person building a Death Star of
communication by eating [ __ ] and
building a very big business and then I
was gonna point that Deathstar the
Vayner X machine against the Crohn's and
Colitis foundation cuz my brother has it
and I want to cure it some business that
somebody comes along that didn't know
how to run it so I bought it for a
million and then I can get it to a
hundred but I realized six seven years
ago [ __ ] I now know who I am let me
build the biggest infrastructure in the
world around it and then whether it's to
help you know hurricane victims or sell
sneakers I'm gonna be able to point this
[ __ ] thing so for me I don't look at
my ebody I don't care how much we're
growing I've made a 20-year decision
that I'm in the process of and I'm gonna
execute against that and the numbers and
dollars are just not the way I score if
you've been lucky enough to have a
success you've had and you're this young
I would take a big step back and try to
figure out you know what is like the
most fun or the most macro thesis you
can come up with great thanks you're
welcome
guys thank you for having me
thanks Dawson thank you so much hope you
enjoyed that keynote
now the question from it what was your
biggest new takeaway from the talk in
Boise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]